greetings you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 3rd of march
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter listen
good help is hard to find it's like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job online or at
the cork board down at the [__]
coffee shop
but then you gotta sit there and hope
the right person walks by
and sees it well stop dreaming go to zip
recruiter for free
right now at ziprecruiter.com
they do all the work for you one click
and your job gets sent to over 100 top
job sites and here's where it gets
freaky that matching technology hooks
you up
with the people with the skills and
experience that you need
and right now you could try zip recorder
for free troy what are you talking about
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey joy why do i need zip recruiter
because zip recruit is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day listen
this is your business you got no time to
be looking at resumes and
interviewing goofy people go to zip
recruiter right now
for free give it a spin go to
ziprecruiter.com
joey ziprecruiter.com joey
try it for free just by going to
ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hide
the join is also brought to you by c b
d lion let me tell you something
they proved to me over the surgery the
strength that cbd lion has
you don't know how many nights i was saw
and i would go in my bathtub
and throw in one of the bath balls who
the hell has cbd bath balls
cbd lion does again i come out of the
bat
what would i rub on my leg the cream the
thousand milligram cream
boom on my leg then
before i [__] uh put my pajamas on at
night
i put the cbd kinesiology tape on my
knee
everything's all settled i go downstairs
i put ice on it
do you get where i'm going with this cbd
line was three quarters
of my recovery let me explain something
to you i'm done with the pain pills
six weeks whatever i'm done i threw 13
of the oxycontins away
and the vikings are in the drawer if you
want one come over i'll give it to you
but you don't need it cbd lion's got you
covered go to cbdlion.com
read up on cbd cbn cby
and the benefits and how it can help you
with whatever problem that might be
bothering you i'm not saying that
it's the end-all be-all but let me tell
you something it's tremendous
go to cbdlinerock.com right now
and press in church or joey and get
twenty percent off of see the
cbdlion.com delivered right to your
house no [__]
no guy at the liquor store some [__]
mutt with a [__]
hat on trying to sell you a cbd go to
cbd lion
read read this is the help that you've
been needing for a long time he didn't
know where to start
so go to cbdline.com right now precious
church or joey
and get this party started and now we're
gonna get our party started you
understand me
let's fly a little candle here for the
espiritos malos
and let's get this show on the road
hey how you doing come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 3rd of march
you [__] believe it's the 3rd of
march ready where the [__] did the year
go
thank you very much for watching the
doug stanhope podcast
and enjoying it listen uh i've said it a
thousand times
people reach out to me all the time and
they're like listen do you want to zoom
and i'm like i really don't know you
so the relationship when you zoom and
you don't know a person
it's very rough you know i zoom with
ryan sickler
i'll zoom with lee i'll zoom with doug
stanhope but it's very tough to zoom
with people
you're not tight with or you don't have
a relationship with that gap
zoomers already kind of have like a
[__] gap
i watched the first 15 minutes of it
listen i hate watching myself
i watched two minutes of it just to see
the lighting and everything how it looks
but i watched that [__] podcast for a
little while
and what i felt from that podcast was
love you know a lot of love between
two guys that had been around
i had you know stan hope
left in 2005 like he said on the podcast
and i had a really really seen him and
in a way he was kind of like my rock
and you know things spun out of control
for me
i mean you know we went out both
directions and
as soon as i landed here since the
minute i landed in new jersey
you know i've been asking myself what
happened you know i've been back tracing
the steps of what happened you know
and doug stanhope's name has been on my
mind
every [__] day for the last three
months like he's just
one of the guys that really helped me
and i
never really got a chance to thank him
and i wanted to thank him and that's
what that podcast was
you know the reason i'm here is because
of him because
he convinced me to move to los angeles
and not only that when i got to los
angeles
he was my friend and he treated me with
the utmost respect and
you know that's just to let you guys
know how how [__] up i was listen i'm
not making no excuses
i never make excuses to you people i i
love you too much
snorting coke and eating the german
girl's [__] i mean snorting heroin
and eating german girls [__] did i ever
tell you that story
i didn't even [__] remember it that's
how [__] up i was
that that just goes to show you how
[__] up i was
this girl was a knockout and once a week
after every two weeks
i would see her at the corner store and
we would talk
and she'd go i just picked up a bag and
i walked down to a house
i'd do a little [__] line she was
beautiful
thin and she would play with herself and
let me the [__] that was it she
wouldn't let me [__] she didn't want
no dick in her
she had her reasoning whatever but how
crazy is that
i would go over there do a line of
heroin and then she'd take off a pen he
said eat her [__] she'd come
and then we'd talk for 10 minutes and
i'd leave and i wouldn't see her for two
weeks
this is my life and i got no excuses
i was [__] up if i can't remember that
that just goes to show you you know a
couple
months ago somebody reached out and said
they were
a little bit uncomfortable with me uh
that i had
hit on them 20 years ago over 20 years
ago
and that they were uncomfortable with me
when they well they went to hari and
already explained to him did he take his
dick out and they said no
he just hit on me and then we kept
snorting coke and i drove him home
and he goes what's the problem you know
what was the problem that
well i always felt uncomfortable at you
know
after after that well
you never said it before you you know i
didn't even know what the [__] i was
talking about
i lost my train of thought
yeah you know but um but the point that
i was trying to make was what i [__]
forgot
you know what what what difference does
it make it was 22 [__] years ago
did he take his dick out or anything he
goes diaz was on [__]
coke and [__] coked up and heroined
up and i said ari that's no excuse
that's never an excuse just some is on
coke or heroin
i never lay that excuse on people my
actions were done by me
i could sit here and tell you i
kidnapped ken bella because the dentist
put me out that morning
i didn't do that did i did i say that
did i have i ever said that
i had my teeth done the morning i
kidnapped that kid and they put me under
with gas so everybody told me that you
could use it as a defense
yeah because it affected how i thought
but
that's a [__] excuse for a punk
that's an excuse a punk makes
you know listen i'm a punk i was a punk
back then
and i was [__] out of my mind but
that just goes to show you guys the
power of the pen
the love i had for comedy and the effect
that my wife had on me
because guys i remember snorting listen
when i talked to you guys about heroin i
told jews that i did it when i was
17 with gunther brown and then i
revisited again when i was in
prison i didn't know what i was doing i
snorted it it was brown heroin
tar and they put it in my nose with like
a [__]
like a thing that you put under your
tongue like one of that nothing happened
then one time i think i snorted like a
powder and heroin or something
and i got sick i was never a big heroin
guy then 2007
was when bonehead the legend of bonehead
was sending me little three dollar bags
from newark
and i was doing them on monday but after
yeah i forgot
all about you know i never shot everyone
nothing like that
but uh i forgot all about that that i
used to get i mean that was a complete
different time
97 to 2000 for me
was such a [__] blur because
i had just landed in l.a i was hanging
out with doug
you know josh wolfe we you know doug was
way above us
at that time doug was our mentor you
know
we'd walk into a place with doug like
[__] you [__] we're with doug stanhope
you know what i'm saying
so doug mentored me doug took me under
his [__] wing
doug taught told me what to say doug was
the one that told me that that joke that
joe rogan loves uh
uh you know beat a [__] who would you
know if you beat a [__]
who they gonna call who they gonna
believe me or do with a wig and a black
guy you know what i'm saying
that was with doug stanhope doug stanley
said that's a bit
write that because somebody said
something about a [__] on the block or
something and they were like what
you know what you're going to have to
train them like who they going believe
me or some dude with a wiggling a black
eye and that stuck and joe rogan loved
it
doug loved it but those were my
influences man
you know the day that i really had
reached out to doug
was the day about the sierra bonita
shooting when they shot
lady gaga's dog walker
listen it's a giggle whatever
nah that the kid didn't die he's alive
and kicking he just wrote in the
instagram
and then the dogs were recovered i don't
know what happened i wasn't there but
let me tell you something
sierra bonita was our neighborhood
sierra bonita was is a street and
it was sierra bonita kirsan
vista and gardner
you know and everybody lived on those
streets and sierra bonita was mitch
hedberg and nick the power he said
there's a thousand [__] times
and that was just such a great name but
i would see stevo
going into the there was a concursion on
the corner curson
there's a 7-eleven and right across the
street there's a liquor store it's
perfect
i used to see stevo i'm talking about 98
2000 i was getting [__] up
and i would see him going to the liquor
store walking out with a case of beer
and then going to 7-eleven
and getting two cartons of smokes when
you see somebody getting two cottons of
smoke
you know they're going into the deep
underworld deep
deep [__] underworld two cartons of
smokes jesus christ
i would go home with two packs of
cigarettes or something
two cottons of cigarettes you're not
going out for a few [__] days
so it was just when that thing happened
on sierra bonita it didn't happen on
sunset
it happened maybe a block up north maybe
a block and a half up north towards
hollywood boulevard
that hit home with me and it made me
think about ralphie and mitch and
[__] you know doug and then just
you know that story about oh my god
about the [__]
uh the night at the coaching horses
coaching horses
was a dive bar that was cooler than
[__] i saw some wild [__] in there
and i used to go in there when i was
[__] up
and when i first got to l.a
i didn't have a car and doug lent me a
car one day
to go get a an audition i had an
audition
and i had to go to downtown l.a this is
like the freakiest [__] story like
like when i lived with doug the weirdest
[__] happened all right i'm living with
doug
and i go to [__] and i go doug i gotta
borrow your car doug didn't wake up till
12.
i woke up at nine i needed a day job so
i was gonna go look for a telemarketing
job
i told doug before i'm gonna borrow your
car it's a friday morning
check it out check out the computer
whatever it's a friday morning
it either had to be january
of 97
or february of 97. i don't know if you
can look up the date
uh it was a north hollywood shooting
when the guy was walking down the street
with the body armor and [__]
that's the day i woke up got in doug's
car
at 8 45 to do an interview at nine
and i got to the 101. i'll never forget
this as i was entering the 101 february
28th
who the [__] do you think you're dealing
with because i got to la january
i don't know 29th or something like that
i got made a regular february 19th
and i was living with doug until about
march april
and i still remember leaving doug's
house
and getting to the 101 and my pager
going off
and when i went to
pull over to call it was the job telling
me not to come up that there's a mass
shooting in north hollywood by the
officers
it turned out years later i lived in
that neighborhood
they showed me where all the bullets and
all this [__] was going 2
000 rounds oh no no it was insane the
was backed up so if i would have got on
the 101
i would have never i would have ran out
of gas because in those days
he meant enough for me he meant enough
you know what i'm saying
whenever he's on e it's like enough it's
enough don't worry about nothing
at least till the red light comes on we
got nothing but [__] hope and dreams
worst case scenario pissing a gas tank
but i never forget
going up highland pulling over
and then calling on don't come up here
because they're shooting all bullets
and me going okay and i [__] turned
around and went home
and then like the following week
at this point i wasn't living with doug
anymore it had to be like a month or two
later
i had moved out of doug's but i still
borrowed his car
he lends me his car to go to an audition
for an abc show
guys i was as green as [__] i didn't
know
what the [__] was going on
i go to this audition i walk in i see
rudy moreno old comic friend of mine
brilliant guy
used to run the brave bull comedy he
gives me a big hug i'm in l.a you know
at this point
maybe four five months
you know i'm a regular at the store i'm
[__] out there banging it out
and on the way back under the five by
dodgers stadium i get a flat
by uh silver lake
it's called silver lake and i end up on
silver lake boulevard and i go
i know one person who lives on here this
chick marilyn martinez right
so i call marilyn martinez up rest in
peace one of my dear dear friends
love doug loved it too because she was
crazy she loved doug
they loved each other they were both
dirty and they would follow each other
at the store and [__]
and i called marilyn he's the only
person i know when i go maryland i got a
[__] flat
i got i don't even know where to start
it's not my car i'm embarrassed it's
doug's car
she goes don't worry about none where
are you i go i'm at
some park this is craziness guys okay
i'm at some park lamert park one of
those [__] parks
down it wasn't downtown l.a i'm lying to
you it's in silver lake
and it was around there there's a big
park behind silver lake
if anybody remembers it while they just
tweet me and let me know to refresh my
memory
again look up at this date maybe
i don't know i don't know what the date
is maybe
let's go with may of 97 okay
so it's may of 97. i call maryland i go
man i don't know what to do i'm
stuck i'm by this [__] park
and i'm pulled over she goes don't worry
where are you i told them by the park
there's a statue there's a water
fountain going up in silver lake or
whatever it's called
she goes my husband david's gonna go
pick you up i had never met a husband
he's a black dude
he was a [__] [__] bad [__]
years later i ended up put bringing him
to the longest yard
and telling them that he was my
probation officer and
[__] him and burt reynolds were
talking for hours and [__]
but i take this [__]
dave crowd it comes but he comes with a
white looking dude
and david says says to me this is my
brother-in-law
he's cuban just like you he just got out
of prison three days ago
hey man what's happening hey hola you
know
i hug him and [__] and this young you
know the whole [__] deal
and we start talking he takes me to this
mexican place that sells tires
like 10 bucks and they put them on for
you you know no no drama
just a nice tire nothing spectacular 10
15 bucks 10 bucks to just put it on
and he puts it on and then they go what
do you want to do like i don't know
whatever you guys want to do
and we went and we went like that tell
this story we went and got cuban food
but before this whole thing happens i'm
waiting for them at the park right
i'm minding my own business you can't
write this
this is why you cannot write joey diaz's
[__] life story because
there's too much [__] i'm sitting at
this park
it's a nice day out i don't know 70 60
degrees i'm minding my business i don't
know
nobody i'm waiting for dave
and all of a sudden i see a car
you know and he's like driving
erratically right
so he comes around the thing and then i
hear a helicopter and then i see [__]
four cop cars it had to be right i'm
sitting in my
own [__] business it's a beautiful
day to be alive birds are chirping
you know the whole [__] deal
what the [__] do you think happens next
g
the car pulls around the guy that they
were chasing
this [__] pulls around gets out
of the car
right gets out of the car gets behind
this
i mean opens up his door i'm watching
all this
it's 500 yards from me
maybe i'm 33 34 97
so i had way better eyesight you know
and it was like that scene
and the godfather one two
when she goes to visit the godfather and
she tells them my son's [__] don't
don't kill him you know spare his life
and then she has a knife and he blows
her away with a gun
dog that's exactly what i saw live and
in color
i don't think i don't think i've ever
said this on a [__] podcast
so i see this [__] he is driving
right and also he just goes and he turns
the car around does a full 360.
pops his [__] passenger door open
gets
out of the car and starts shooting at
the cops
i'm watching all this the helicopters
above i'm like oh
my [__] god
like no i wasn't in the car i was
sitting on the hood uh
why am i standing in a hot car for i
want to see i want to get some vitamin d
and all of a sudden the guy's like
and he looks like this and i see him run
across like he had like a maybe a
30-yard run
to the thing or he pulls over
and he starts shooting at him and a cop
just [__] wasted him
with like a [__] pump gun some type
of shotgun just
boom and the guy was like and they
caught him as he was gonna go and he
just took him
and he went like maybe four feet he
landed
i was like the helicopter came down even
lower and make sure he was dead
and the cops [__] rushed in and
that's when
[__] david and my friend came and i
go
you just [__] missed it the cops just
shot a dude right there i mean
and dog listen if the cops weren't
interviewing me now
about it years later the cops were solid
on this call
i saw the whole [__] thing i saw the
guy do the 360.
get out of his car and get behind the
passenger door he [__] kept the glass
up when he shot through the glass
that's all like that's how it started
hearing it but i saw the whole thing go
down
boom boom boom he shot maybe four times
he reacted they were shooting at him and
then he
shot like to go into an alley but while
he was shooting he was like you know
tata like in the movies
and bro something like they were
shooting handguns at him but at one
point some guy just [__] got him
right in the [__] chest
and he went back just saw the explosion
and and
that was it dog so he takes me over
we [__] get the tire fixed and then
we go to silver lake and we eat at some
cuban joint like this at
cochinito and he takes her to a cuban
bakery the whole [__] thing
and you know you know me you're sitting
there 500
or whatever from this shooting they
didn't say anything to you
the cops yeah not a word
[Music]
not a word didn't even were you like the
only one around
there was there were some people at a
park you know there was some kids
playing like not it was
it was a big park with a fountain in the
middle
like a fountain torch three quarter side
not really in the middle
it happened on the other side of the
park and i was over here
so it was a good far distance
there were people there no investigator
came up to me and asked me by the time
they got there
we just basically took the tire off the
car and drove it to the mexican place
and then we came back and put the tire
on
and that's when they were still tagging
the body they had the cones around
they had the whole [__] they just
shot this [__] with a shotgun
boom so we're talking about
it's about six o'clock now and i don't
know you know
i don't know how it gets mentioned he
says he's got cocaine for sale i go
jesus christ you told the right person
because i'm in the market i'm looking
so he goes i'll have it at 8 o'clock or
something
you know you have to come back to silver
lake
so i went i gave dug back his car
and i think i borrowed josh wolf's car
and i went up to this cuban's house
and he sold me an 8-ball of some [__]
that i could smell it when i walked into
the apartment
like this guy was not [__] around he
was three days out of prison
and he had already met the dude and he
was slinging
so he gave me a nice price i think i got
an eight ball
let me tell you something i had no
comedy that night
i never figured i had no comedy that
night so i started early
you know that was one it was like a
tuesday mitzi didn't give me a spot or
something
i was just [__] around bro now my
tolerance for cocaine
at this time was pretty high i was 10
years away from quitting
but my tolerance was pretty [__] high
you know i had been i could do a gram
and not blink an eye in those days like
two lines
and just sit there for an hour and not
say nothing or talk
[__] because i was chatty kathy when i
did coke
let me tell you something i'll never
forget driving back from silver lake
with that eight ball
getting into hollywood and going by josh
wolf's house
and doing like two or three lines with
him
he was going to do something and me
doing like [__] hate lines
and i mean when i tell you i walked into
the coaching horses
i didn't say a word david fulton tweeted
today
thank you for mentioning us and whatever
i still remember joey
filled with peruvian glue and his mouth
was shut
i mean i couldn't even [__] talk that
is no lie
my mouth was [__] shut i remember
them talking to me i couldn't sweat
i couldn't do anything i still remember
what i did that night this is how
disgusting
and creepy i was i [__] got so
hammered at that coaching horses by 11
30 i was so coked up
and every time i looked in the bag there
was still tons of coke left i'm like
dog this is going to be a long [__]
night
so i stayed there as long as i could
before i started getting creepier and
creepier
because i'm a creepy [__] guy as it
is never mind putting cocaine in me the
creepiness
really comes the [__] out and i'll never
forget i had this car
and i went across the street i bought a
[__]
two six-packs and i went in this car i
had a moon roof
and i [__] pushed the seat all the
way back
and it was i was staying on vista like
um
four carloads up from josh wolf under a
tree
that's when i lived in that car you ever
hear the car i lived in
they got my apartment got towed that's
when i had that car and i'll never
forget that
i went back to that car
and i would drink do lines i couldn't
talk
i didn't want anybody to see me there
was a blanket in the trunk
and i left this because i would live in
the car from time to time
you know it was my travel car to go on
the road i would put the seat back put
the blanket over me
i'm right in the driver's seat i would
try to jerk off
the coke and i couldn't jerk off because
my dick would shrink
it was a [__] nightmare that was one
of the worst cocaine nights
of my life that coke was so [__]
tremendous
like i'm telling you i couldn't talk and
i still remember it was me
doug david fulton his buddy that he
always hangs out with
josh wolf i think it was like tana
new there was like eight of us run not
everybody was doing coke like
those guys don't do coke full no stand
up i was the only coke fan
but i was so [__] up i will never ever
forget how embarrassing i was that night
couldn't even talk
couldn't even say a [__] word and
usually
like i have a friend he does he never
talks but he does coke and
he doesn't talk because he stutters but
when he does coke he doesn't stutter
it's the weirdest thing
he does too that's how i know he's doing
coke when he calls me he's like
pavarotti
oh solo when he's doing
when he's not doing coke attack how are
you doing
what do you mean he sounds like lee's
cousin yeah but when he's [__]
doing coke oh he's straight as an arrow
he's singing kenny rogers songs and [__]
like that
[Music]
so yeah it was uh it was just two guys
seeing each other that haven't seen each
other in a long time
and i was very happy i was very happy
for the memories i'm happy that you guys
got to hear the memories that
we shared with ralphie and his mother
god rest her soul
she had old uh
uh breasts like
mrs stanhope had breast implants like in
they were made from wood like a tit to a
heart and she would
she would ask you from time to time feel
them feel them if you want and you're
like
miss stanhope how long do i mean guys it
was a great
listen it was a lot different than when
it became
things weren't so serious you know he
said it himself
mitch hedberg wrote the joke when we
used to play tennis
down at gorky park because it was a
russian parks like we call it gorky park
i mean we were down there three four
nights a [__] week day playing tennis
you know comedy was fun i i didn't know
what i was doing
i was a young kid i was lee i was
basically a lee
hanging out with doug stanhope mitch
hedberg
and hanging out at the comedy [__]
club and learning from those guys
it was just uh the ultimate i mean i was
i i when i saw doug stanhope
like i had met doug in 91 or 92 and then
we worked together in 93.
then he won san francisco
doug came back to seattle in 96
and did a weekend and this is what
changed joe diaz you know we do the
album of the week
and i show you about my influences you
know the people who influence me with
music whether
i do the album of the week on patreon so
i'm sorry if a lot of guys don't see it
uh when i do the album of the week it's
it's not
from i don't go on rolling stone i don't
go on [__] whatever and look at what
albums are popular i'm telling you what
created my musical taste when i throw
different albums at you
you know what's this week elton john
you know goodbye yellow brick road you
know last week was volume four
you know every week i throw a different
album on you but the
you know what is what joey
what is the comparison between elton
john
and doug and doug stanhope and uh and
black sabbath
there's no connection there's no elton
john
doing black sabbath you never seen
sabbath covering [__] uh
you know hello baby hello wow
no no you don't see that [__] happening
that's as far as a genre as you can see
the difference i had to do the same
thing with comedy because that's how he
learned to be a good comic
you know i'm a dirty comic but i'm a big
fan of john mulaney's
you know because he works clean i think
it take you know i hope he's doing well
he was in a rehab i hope he's out
and he's handling his [__] business
like a man most people were goofing on
him
because he had the courage to go to a
[__] rehab people just have no
[__] respect for anybody anymore
these days but
doug stanhope was one of those guys that
i looked at
that june i remember we were gonna go
see atlantis morrissette that saturday
65 tickets i was furious
my girlfriend at the time but that
friday night
i went to see doug stanhope and i
laughed so hard
it made me depressed because
i knew i would never be as good as a
comic
as doug stanhope he was on a different
[__] level in 96.
in my world right now in my eyes i'm a
huge fan
of bill burrow i think bill burr is god
i think when i think about
what a stand-up is i think immediately
to bill burr
and then we have different styles we
have joe rogan has a different style
i have more of a storytelling style
theo's a story
telling style but the true
lenny bruce of our generation is not
dave chappelle it's not joe rogan it's
none of those guys it's not
and i'm not saying that they're bad
comics they're great comics that
they influenced me they they [__] you
know dave chappelle i
you know i watch everything patrice
o'neill all these guys are great comics
but for me the real lenny bruce of
my career was doug stano
because while everybody else tried
not to be hollywood he wasn't hollywood
all those other comics will tell you
they're not hollywood
they're hollywood if you're telling me
you're not hollywood it's because you're
hollywood
you don't have to tell me we see it we
see it
doug stanhope told the industry to go
[__] themselves the biggest lesson
that i learned from doug stanhope was
you don't need nobody
if you work on your craft i don't care
if you do triple runs and nobody sees
you
if you work on your craft you disappear
for five years
they're gonna [__] know who the [__]
you are whether you like it or not
doug stanhope didn't give a [__] about
tv
he didn't give a [__] about anything in
the height of comedy in 2005
he picked up his bags and moved to
bisbee arizona
and told the industry to suck his dick
that's what a real [__] comic does
do you understand me we go against him
you know he
uh him and sean rouse did a [__] show
sean rouse god rest his soul funny
[__]
and i guess doug stand up went up there
made fun of the owner's son
and he banned them from all the funny
bones and improvs did you think that
stopped doug stanhope
[__] he went and got bars all across
the street from those clubs
and sold them out now he can play
whatever improv he want or funny bone he
wants to
because he [__] shut him the [__]
down that's what a real comic does
we don't play into their [__] hands
we're running the [__] game [__]
and he's proven it all along he went to
bisbee while everybody else is fighting
do you think that the comedy store was
great
but if stan hope is there during this
whole thing
it would have been the [__] cherry on
the [__] sunday it would have been a
club that
the wrath of that club would have been
it would have been just too much it was
he would have really added because his
style of comedy
is very unique very funny
very intelligent it comes off from some
far out [__] places you know
and and it's not just that it's his
lifestyle
you know he you heard him he bought a
car from a friend of mine
he used my friend's [__] address for
his license
and a [__] ad you know this guy was
just
living a life that most people dream
about living
because they're not controlled by
anybody you can't tell duck stand up not
to do a joke
neither can me you know what [__]
savages we're cut from the same cloth
i learned a lot as much from him as i
did from joe rogan
joe rogan had the more professional
style that's why joe rogan made the 100
million dollars and did the other stuff
doug was more of a purist doug won't do
it for the money doug doesn't give a
[__] about the money
it's like me i don't give a [__] about
stand up money
i love you don't get paid for stand up
you get paid for the [__] that comes
along with it
the flights and the [__] waiting and
get to your hotel after you haven't
slept and the room isn't ready and you
know
people coming up to you afterwards with
bad breath and talking to you
about episode 629 and how you were wrong
about the [__] whatever
you know there's always [__]
something so what i'm trying to say to
you is
uh you know stan was a genius and i'm
happy i had him on the show
and i'm happy you [__] guys enjoy
them because
i've been different since i talked to
them you know i've had a hard time here
the last six months uh the last five
we've done the podcast
and mike has helped me tremendously to
push through
whatever anxiety and fears and whatever
the [__] i was going through i mean it's
rough
i'm gonna i'm just a [__] dad now in
this in suburbia
i live in [__] suburbia i'm in
[__] i'm a suburbian [__] dad
living in the sticks loving it you know
just loving it today i got up i went to
the gym
i talked to the girl i'm writing the
book with my partner we did a half hour
45 minutes on the phone
that's coming along just fine but i do
have a little sadness in my heart today
i want to talk to you about
it's been a year today officially
since i've been at the comedy store
it's been a year since i've been on the
main room stage
it's been a year since i've been in the
original room because i did both shows
that night
it's been a year since i hugged ali wong
tonight march 3rd
this is tonight was the last night i
went down there i walked in
people were talking about social
distancing i guess
nobody at the comedy store got the memo
and uh yeah nobody at the store got in
the memo there was no [__] nothing
i remember walking into that comedy
store on a tuesday night and it was
mobbed and i just got back from vegas
and i'm like
what the [__] is this [__]
and i just wasn't feeling it i went into
the bar the ball was packed
it wasn't till i went into the main room
and i went into the green room i saw
they had no windows my anxiety shot up
i went by the door i got some oxygen
and i remember trying to sneak out as
fast as possible
seeing ali giving her a hug telling her
she looked beautiful and i just walked
out
and got in my car and never went back
i didn't know that night that was gonna
be my last night there i'm not gonna
tell you i did
[Music]
i knew it was over when they told me a
week later they closed
the store that's when i had a feeling i
wouldn't be up there once i made the
commitment to come to the store i
[__] uh
i went to the store on sunday with my
family
and i put my hand against the wall and i
thanked it
i thanked the spirits i thanked the wall
i thanked the building i sat on the
stairs
you know i'll post i think i got the
pictures in here
i'll post one of them on patreon
but uh and on twitter for you if you'd
like for you guys but yeah i uh
i uh took pictures
of the uh of
my last day at the store i went on a
sunday and i just walked around i walked
around the whole building
i went all the way to the back you know
where jeff scott used to sit and i
[__] sat back there for a minute
and then i walked around to the back
door and i sat on those steps
how many nights i saw those steps
talking to
great [__] minds from joe rogan to
eddie griffin
to paul mooney and i don't know how many
nights i sat there
talking to andrew dice clay him giving
me advice you know sebastian
we were just young [__] knuckleheads
getting advice from a [__] elderly
you know andrew dice clay i i i just
cannot tell you cannot tell you you know
so
that podcast monday was great because uh
it settled me down i got to see one of
my old buddies
and i think we're gonna do this once a
month me and stan hope
just once a month [__] around
and uh telling stories telling crazy
road stories
i went on the road with them a couple of
times we'll save those i'd even go into
those
i went on the road maybe twice once to
harvey's in portland
and once to a club in wisconsin i think
i think i
cancelled him on that one he was pissed
at me
but uh when i brought him on it was just
to thank him for being my friend
i was how [__] lucky was i
how lucky was i man that god put
stan hope in my life and then
like what i was trying to explain to you
before it just wasn't stanhope i had
rick dukeman in my corner
then paul mooney was in my corner and
then [__] joe rogan got in my corner
then ralphie may was in my corner and it
was like you know
i'm getting mentored by when i met
ralphie
ralphie was a no name but he was already
headlining ralphie
i wasn't headlining when i met ralphie
ralphi could already do an
hour 20. i wasn't even close to that
[__]
but those conversations with ralphie and
doug
you know we mentioned celine henrosa
god rest her soul she passed a few years
ago
this chick was our friend she
became she went on doug's show doug had
a
13 episode uh deal with fox
a hidden camera show did you even know
that if you could ever find those
if anybody could find those online get
ready to laugh it's just pranks
he was the best and there's one
particular when
uh the limo driver has to give him a
ride to the airport and when the limo
driver shows up he goes
we got a problem my grandmother died we
got to drop her off
at the hospital you don't know how many
limo drivers took off there was one
arabian guy
he's like we'll do it they taped grandma
they taped the stat like it was a fake
thing and they put a blanket over
and they put it on top of an suv and
they duct taped
this guy said for an extra hundred we'll
do whatever you need to do
and he drove then they showed doug going
into a pizza parlor
with a cat with a dead cat in a box like
what looked like a dead cat
he's like excuse me i was finished i was
cooking this cat
and i [__] i [__] uh
in my oven blue do you mind putting this
in your pizza and finishing the cat
up and the guy would open it up and
there's like a half a dead cat that was
really fake
and the guy throw would throw dug out it
was just it was 13 episodes if you could
find it
find it but yeah today is uh
a very listen i did so many things i
didn't
even had a chance to absorb it if i was
sad or not but i am a little bit off
uh i lost my
i lost my world yesterday a year ago
today i lost my world
i thought it was just gonna be for a
couple weeks
and uh here we are a year later and the
comedy store still closed
my my heart goes out to them i don't
know what they're gonna do you know
i'm not them i don't have to pay those
mortgages or
i don't have to pay all that stuff so
whatever they decide to do
they have my blessing because i got what
i needed out of them and they got what
they needed from me
and we were solid to each other so uh
this year has been very hard for me you
know
this move has been very hard for me i
know a lot of guys
have watched me and said you know joey
we could see kind of that something hey
it's i'm i'm fighting something that
i'm starting to accept now i'm accepting
my new role
as a suburban a suburbia dad in the
sticks
you know i got the next four or five
weeks of uncle vinnie's
starting tonight i got a guest spot
tonight
uh i'm excited about all this stuff and
uh
you know i'm wishing for the best you
know i don't know what's going to happen
after march but i will tell you what i
i read emails you know you guys know i
read your emails and stuff like that
i got an email from a friend of mine i
would like a a comic friend of mine he
goes did you read this
somebody had posted that the reason
i didn't move to austin they didn't say
nothing negative
they just said we love joey
but we know why he didn't move to austin
because
joe wasn't going to let him on the
podcast because of
spotify let me explain something to you
i wasn't going to austin either way
i told you guys that in april
the week that they shut march march 9th
march 10th i was supposed to be here
march 11th i was supposed to be at
uh whatever poughkeepsie i don't [__]
know nyack
and then the next two days three days i
already had a realtor
who was going to show me a few houses up
north
once the pandemic the pandemic canceled
you know i got a shot in my knee and my
knees roll up so i had to cancel tuesday
i had to cancel [__] wednesday and by
wednesday they were already
saying in bergen county teaneck was
spreading
and there was another part or orchid
park or whatever
so that stopped me from coming to new
york to purchase a home
and then when joe rogan called me and he
goes hey i'm moving to austin
and i want to buy you a house 10
10 out of 10 people would buy a [__]
house
would let somebody buy them a house i
love joe rogan
i didn't need for him to buy me a house
i love him with all my heart
the office still on the table i could
call him to mom and say
i'm selling this [__] crib and i'm
moving down i'm sure the office stormed
the table
but if you think i didn't move down
there because i couldn't get on the
podcast
do you guys actually think i'm that
shallow
is that what you think of me that i'm
not shallow that i wouldn't live down
there because of a [__] podcast
i've been on the podcast 20 times and as
all
you guys known i destroyed them every
time you like bon jovi says
i've seen a million faces and i rocked
them all
how many times i go on that podcast and
rock that [__]
i did my job i don't need to go back on
there no more
him and i speak all the [__] time we
spoke last night you know we spoke two
nights ago and last night
we had a pleasant conversation i think
he's gonna buy something down there it's
not
my liberty to discuss what the [__] he's
gonna buy
but i'll be there and i'm not even gonna
tell you what i'm gonna do that podcast
with
i'm going to surprise you [__]
next time i do the jre podcast
i'm going on there with the king
you guys your jaws are going to drop new
jersey
your jaws are going gonna drop i'm gonna
go on there with
i'm not gonna tell you when i'm not
gonna tell you
who i'm just gonna i want you to just
see
joey diaz and the name you're gonna see
next to it
and all your wigs are gonna [__] fall
off so
but that's not happening till august or
september so
don't get in a [__] uh pickle yet but
i'll be in austin
not anytime soon but i'll be in austin
i'll be down there
visiting him hanging out i want to see
red band i spoke to red band the night
and like i've always told people
the day i die the guy that's going to
cry the loudest is going to be red band
and he's going to be meaning it because
we definitely love each other we were so
excited
to talk to each other i talked to
crystalia last week he's doing great
i spoke to ali wong last week she's
doing great
you know doug stanhope i check in man
gotta check in with these [__]
savages theo vaughn
one [__] i didn't talk to his
josh roof i gotta give that [__] sucker
a call
[__] jewish shooting especially he
forgets about his uncle [__] joey
these [__]
but uh i gotta talk to you guys about
something before we wrap this up
sunday i'm in a good mood i get stoned
you know we don't have to do the podcast
until monday i'm having a great time
the girls went to uh a friend of theirs
from l.a that moved here also so i had a
few hours to myself
you know i'm smoking some bones uh
i think i went i went to the gym i went
to the gym i came back
once i go to the gym i rode the bike for
15-20 minutes
i felt good and i started [__] around
on periscope now i'm gonna tell you guys
something okay
so i start [__] around on periscope
and guess what
some guy starts calling me
a 201 number okay now he keeps calling
he keeps calling
then he keeps texting he keeps texting
he thinks it's cute you know he thinks
it's really cute
me i laugh i want you guys to all know
something
the 323 number i have everybody's got
that one
you're my friends i love you to death it
rings
a hundred times a day and i'm not
picking it up
i decided about two years ago that if i
picked up
every call i had every day i wouldn't
have time to do anything
i'm dead serious there was a bunch of
people listening to the podcast i give
you know not phone numbers to you give
them they call you once
they call you every day and it becomes
it just gets out of control
people i have a daughter i gotta take it
through events i do things with
wives i'm at meetings i'm getting calls
from people
that should not be calling me at two in
the [__] afternoon
so about a year ago way before a year
ago
about a year ago yeah it was last in
fact it was last march
before the pandemic i i got a new phone
it's a private phone even if you get a
private investigator
you can't find it as a matter of fact as
of today only 16 people have that phone
17 when i give it to mikey next because
i'll give it to mike so
it's people who matter to me that i
can't miss their calls
because this phone has become such a
[__] circus
so you know you could call let me tell
you something
that 323 number if you find it you could
call it to your face turn screen
nobody's ever going to answer it
nobody's ever gonna answer it and i and
if
like i know and if you
it's funny if i actually find like if
you leave a message
and you're annoying i actually saved the
contact
so when you call i know not to [__]
pick it up
so you could call that number if you
find it online
you could call it until your fingers
turn blue
you're never it's like the people
messenger me
like you missed a call why are you
what would make you think i would pick
up a messenger call
listen to my background i don't want to
talk to nobody i don't know nothing i
don't know i don't want to know about
nothing
i don't want to know about nothing i
know nothing so why do you think
do you really think i'm going to pick up
a [__] hot call
i don't know that's never going to
happen you're gonna have to leave a
message
and you're not gonna hear back from me
yeah on purpose he thought he was
[__] cute you know like
let me break his boy it's something i
would do too
you know [__] uh i did to brody
stevens when he had his
talk show i would text him so
karma's a [__] but just note for
the other people who think it's cute
and find my number and call you could
call a thousand times
that thing will never pick up in fact
these days i don't even take that phone
in the car with me
i put in a [__] draw and i just come
back and see who calls and i'm like
i'm happy i don't have this phone on me
so
this i got a phone that you couldn't
find the [__] number even if you were
in the cia
think about how a person can have a
number
and you can't find it what would i have
to do
so think about it knuckleheads
don't [__] call me don't call me on
that 323 number
you're in no danger you could call it
until you light yourself
on fire if you facetime me and you're on
fire
i'll pick up the phone if i see that if
i see you on fire like on the thing
like joey pick it up i'm on fire then
i'll pick it up out of respect
but unless if you're not on fire don't
call my phone
and for you [__] knuckleheads who i
answered a message on
it says you just missed a call on
messenger listen
i'm always gonna miss the call on
messenger always
i don't even know where to pick up the
phone i'm messing yeah what does the
computer have a phone on the side you're
supposed to [__]
pick it up whatever the [__] your phone
if there's an app
yeah no i don't want to pick i don't
want to talk to nobody listen
the rule still stands it stood with the
church
and it stands with the joint i don't
know nothing
i don't want to know nothing i don't
know who you're talking about
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know nothing
i don't want to meet nobody i don't want
to see nobody i don't want to go to
dinner with nobody
i don't want to smoke with no but i want
to do nothing i'm fine
we say hello we shake hands we give each
other a hug
you take a hike north i'll go [__]
stop i don't know nothing
these people that come and ask me
questions you're asking the wrong
[__] guy you're not gonna get nothing
out of me
you know i'm not a rat i did time did i
not do time
you're not going to get nothing out of
me so please
don't call because you're in no danger
you got a better chance of getting that
suicide hotline
especially today that [__] is [__]
busy people been calling suicide hotline
all week it's a bad [__] time of the
year
it's a bad time of the year for people
so but i'm happy
we got to get to spend together this
beautiful
[__] wednesday i'm going to start off
i'm going to get out of here i'm going
to call my man
i'm going to go on draftkings i got a
game tonight
chicago against new orleans
in [__] new orleans i think a
friend of mine dropped a little dime on
me and said to look at the game the
game's a little awkward
if you go on draftkings always you code
joey and like i said it's easy because
i've been getting into it lately
i'm having a great time just doing
little prop bets
one saturday but i lost sunday you know
it's 25 hours what do i give a [__]
we're just having a good [__] time
here
that's it and that's that for the
[__] uh
joint uncle joey's joint
facebook i'm getting rid of you pretty
soon so it's expect to pull the plug on
facebook
it's going to go down to um
twitch twitter and instagram
no more [__] facebook
and uh patreon that's it and i'm gonna
do a patreon maybe one tier
and that's it give you as much contest
as i can
i'm starting a spanish podcast
called la descarga on patreon then i'm
going to make it
up let me work on it on patreon for two
or three weeks or a month
and then i'll put it out into because
there's no categories
for spanish podcast on itunes so
if anybody knows where i would post this
please contact
mike or myself this new podcast called
la descarga and we're going to talk
about some completely different things
only some all the episodes will be in
spanglish
80 spanish so you do if you don't ablo
this ain't the show for you
but if you want to keep in touch with
uncle joey it might be a thought
it's first going to come on on audio and
then we're going to do a video version
of it at uh
at a studio right here close by but
besides that
i love you guys like i said now for a
word from my sponsors but i want to
thank everybody who sponsors
but i want to thank our biggest sponsors
you [__]
for being here on mondays and wednesdays
with us
i love your [__] stay black and
don't tell them i didn't tell you you
know what i'm saying
[__] them in the ear i love you have a
great weekend see you
monday tip top [__] magoo
all right i want to thank all you
[__] for listening today
for watching on youtube you know i love
you i'm here swinging
swinging during the covert you know most
people [__] gave up or they're
depressed
i'm still over here [__] swinging so
i appreciate
the people who are who still stuck it
out with me because it's only going to
get
[__] better from here on in anyway
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter
listen zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day
listen you know that good help is hard
to find it's like trying to find the
[__] you know
a diamond in here you're not gonna find
it sure you can post your job online
we're at a cork board down at the
[__] cough cafe
you ever see the people hanging out at
the coffee shop you're gonna hire them
you're gonna trust them with your
business or you can just sit there and
hope
the right person walks by and reads your
nah stop dreaming
go to ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey they do the work for you one click
and your job gets sent to over a hundred
of the top job sites and here's where it
gets [__] really freaky
their matching technology hooks you up
with people with the skills and
experience that you're looking for
and that you need get the quality
candidates fast
let them play matchmaker so you don't
have to read through applications and
sit there and
my mother started in kentucky who gives
a [__]
it's a needle in the haystack they'll
find it it in fact
zip recruiter is that effective that
four to five employees who post on there
get the person they looking for within
the first day
and right now you can try ziprecruiter
for free joey
free free free at ziprecruiter.com
showy that's zipperclutter.com joey try
it for free just by going to
ziprecruiter
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hide
we're also brought to you by cbd lion
what
can't uh you know what can i what what
else kind of thing
you want a vape you want a gummy bear
you want kinesiology tape
basketball tincture cbd line is one stop
shopping
what you need to do first before we do
anything is go to cbdlion.com
read just read learn
you know you're sitting there you don't
know what's been bothering you you have
an ailment
a pain an ache you know stress
anxiety go to cbd lion read about cbd
cbn cby about the benefits how cbn cuts
your legs
you know this is just they are
tremendous i've learned so much
and now with the surgery cbd lion was
there from a to z
i mean a to z proven i
used every other product from the gummy
bear the bath wall the kinesiology tape
the tincture the 5 000 milligram [__]
ding [__]
forget about it it makes you feel brand
new even with the oxycontins and all
that garbage i had going through my body
so right now today go to cbdlion.com
right now i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank zip recruiter
i want to thank annette want to thank
who else did we have this week we had
somebody else that was tremendous
movement watches
i want to thank relief band look i got
my little relief band on for my nausea
and tonight there's a great game listen
to me i'm not going to tell you where i
heard it
but the line on chicago at new orleans
is kind of kinky go to draftkings give
them a look i
what else you doing with your time you
might as well uh it's it's it's march
it's march [__] mania you know what
i'm saying check out draftkings put a
little betting what do you give a [__]
25 to watch your game they got a bunch
of little contests
you're bored you can control it stop
being a [__]
jerk off and [__] go to draftkings
you know i love you
have a great weekend and i'll see you
monday morning
tip top [__] magoo
there you go
tomorrow
you